Google phones this is the new Google
pixel - and this is a pixel - Excel
these phones are pretty much like last
year's pixels they're just thinner and
lighter and a little bit cleaner
designed and they're finally waterproof
thank goodness but they still have that
two-tone back the fingerprint reader and
crazy-good cameras all the differences
between these two phones are actually
really minor which is great you're kind
of just picking which size you want the
pixel to has a 5-inch OLED screen and
the XL has a six inch OLED screen they
both have two speakers on the front they
both make the phone calls you get the
idea
personally I like the XL a little bit
better because it has these smaller
bezels and a slightly rounder edge it
just feels a little slicker to me but
maybe you like smaller phones that's
totally fine they're pretty much the
same thing since this is Google you get
all the Google stuff you'd expect to
like the newest version of Android
without any weird customization or
bloatware and I cannot explain to you
how nice that feels with this phone
you'll get faster updates and you won't
get bogged down and Samsung's weird
ideas about design you just get Android
and you get the Google assistant which
is getting better all the time what's
the first thing on my calendar tomorrow
one new thing on this phone is that you
can actually squeeze the sides to get to
Google assistant which theoretically it
makes it faster to get to I say
theoretically because it doesn't really
work all that well if you make it super
sensitive to your squeeze it'll go off
every single time you try to put your
phone in your pocket if you go too far
the other way you have to put it in a
very script just to get it to work I'm
sure there's a sweet spot somewhere but
I haven't found it
Google move the search bar down to the
bottom where your finger can reach it
easier added a handy new widget with
whatever info you need at any time and
has some cool new wallpapers all this
stuff will end up on other Android
phones I'm sure but pixel gets it first
it's fun to be first I mean otherwise
it's just a high-end phone fast
processor good fingerprint reader a
fingerprint readers by the way
no headphone jack ugly adapter for the
no headphone jack USB charging no
wireless charging which sucks day long
battery life the works it's not as
impressive looking as the Samsung Galaxy
s8 or the essential phone but it's just
as powerful and you get pure Android I'm
into pure Android now the camera the
pixel twos is incredible I took this
phone to New Orleans and used it to
shoot Gators in the swamp drunk people
on Bourbon Street other drunk people
other places and almost everything I
shot looks fantastic thanks to Google's
software it really is just software it's
just a 12 megapixel camera on this phone
but Google's algorithms are good enough
at detecting faces that it can do that
soft background portrait mode with one
lense where the iPhone needs to I still
think the iPhones portraits look a
little better but the pixel is pretty
impressive and it can do them with the
selfie cam too this camera can shoot in
slow motion up to 240 frames per second
it has really impressive stabilization
for videos it does HDR and it's amazing
in low-light again almost all of that is
software and here by the way it might be
the best part if you buy a pixel too you
get unlimited storage in Google photos
which means your phone will never run
out of space and you know it's like they
say the best camera is the one that has
space for photos that's what they say
right
just like Apple with the iPhone Google
has big plans for the pixel camera in
the long run right now there's Google
lens which turns your camera into sort
of a visual search engine which is new
and limited but pretty neat this is the
stuff that makes Google interesting it's
that combination of hardware and
software and AI and search and cameras
and all the creepy data Google collects
about you all the time that's what comes
together to make its products unique but
this phone just by itself is fantastic
it does everything high-end phone should
does it all well and has almost no bad
ideas about how a phone should work and
it works if you throw in a pool Google's
not trying to compete with samsung here
it's not trying to have the most power
and the most features like the note 8
it's trying to be more like the iPhone
simple and easy and understandable but
still awesome and powerful plus this
thing takes amazing selfies what else
could you want play the IKEA ASMR video
playing the IKEA yes of our videos on
you too
[Music]